hey everyone this is luca nagoyda and i  am super stoked to be announcing the  launch of my new course on data  visualization with r for ecologists  if you know about my last course about  the basics of r for ecologists  then this course builds up from there  going into more advanced topics such as  gg plot 2 and other really cool features  for plotting in r  r studio this course will be launching  on sunday may 30th that's in less than  two weeks and i can't tell you how  excited i am to finally have this out  and ready  if you've already pre-registered for  this course then fantastic  if you haven't don't worry there's still  time make sure to go to the link below  enter your email address and you'll be  sure to receive more updates as we get  closer to launch date  including some special bonuses i'm  really excited to be sharing this with  you  and look forward to seeing you there  [Music]  you